la siguiente ecuación es cierta para
todos los valores reales de y para los
cuales la expresión de la izquierda está
definida además de es una expresión
polino mihály aquí por supuesto nos dan
nuestra ecuación que es 20 y cuadrada
menos 80 dividido entre de entre 4 y
cuadrada menos 8 y dividido entre kubica
más 9 cuadrada igual a 1 la pregunta es
cómo es de bueno lo que nos está
pidiendo en este ejercicio en realidad
no es resolver una ecuación verdad nos
dice que d es una expresión polinomiales
bien d es una expresión polinomio
y que si descubrimos quien es de
entonces la expresión de la izquierda
verdad tendrá que ser siempre igual a 1
para todo valor real de y para los que
esto que este que está de este lado
digamos esté definido verdad así que la
pregunta es cómo podríamos abordar el
problema y lo primero que se me viene a
la mente es es tratar de escribir esta
expresión como
si multiplicamos por el recíproco de
esta expresión es decir veamos
tendríamos 20 g cuadrada 20 g cuadrada
- 80 todo esto dividido sobre d y
pasamos multiplicando verdad pero para
escribirlo multiplicando tendríamos que
multiplicar por el recíproco de esta
expresión es decir invertir numerador y
denominador entonces sería por jay
cúbica +9 ye cuadrada todo esto dividido
entre 4 y cuadrada menos 8 y y esto
tendría que ser igual a
muy bien entonces la idea ahora es
tratar de encontrar quién es de para lo
cual sería conveniente ir simplificando
algo de todas es de todas estas
expresiones
por ejemplo en este numerador yo puedo
distinguir que hay un 20 como factor
común verdad y tengo la sospecha de que
después quedará como una diferencia de
cuadrados así que veamos qué es lo que
tengo tenemos sería 20 g cuadrada menos
4 verdad 20 por ye cuadradas son 20 y
cuadrada 20 x menos 4 es menos 80 y
después de cuadrada menos 4 se puede
describir como binomios conjugados
verdad es decir vamos a ponerlo así que
más 2 x y menos 2 verdad entonces esto
de aquí ya queda escrito de esta forma
muy bien veamos qué pasa por ejemplo con
el denominador de esta expresión aquí
tendríamos que podríamos factorizar 4 de
verdad
tendríamos 4 y que multiplica a que
menos dos verdad entonces aquí ya
tenemos reescrito esta expresión y es
bueno tenerlo de esta forma porque este
menos 2 se cancelaría con este menos 2 y
ahora vamos a reescribir este numerador
de hecho voy a hacer que se vea bien
podríamos factorizar ye cuadrada que
multiplica hay más verdad entonces ya
tenemos estas expresiones y ahora para
poder digamos ir calculando quien
tendría que ser de lo que podríamos
hacer es multiplicar numeradores y
multiplicar denominadores así que veamos
qué es lo que obtenemos tendríamos 20
por que más 2
y menos 2 que multiplica a que cuadrada
y esto multiplica a que más 9 todo esto
queda en el numerador y luego en el
denominador tendríamos de x 4 y por qué
menos 2 y eso tendría que ser igual a 1
verdad entonces podríamos ver aquí
fácilmente que ye menos 2 se cancela con
éste yemen los dos podríamos cancelar ya
con una de estas y es que se encuentran
aquí como ye cuadrada verdad entonces se
cancelaría el cuadrado digamos y ahora
lo que podríamos hacer para despejar de
es multiplicar ambos lados por d es
decir podríamos multiplicar aquí por d y
aquí multiplicar por d lo que tendríamos
del lado izquierdo es que las des se
cancelan verdad y de hecho todavía
podríamos simplificar más verdad tenemos
20 entre 4 así que si dividimos entre 4
nos queda aquí
y aquí uno entonces en resumen lo que
obtenemos es lo siguiente tendríamos
cinco por yemas 2% por yemas 9
quizás quizás debería escribir lo mejor
así tendríamos primero el 5 luego
tomamos y luego tomamos ye más 2 y
finalmente yemas 9 y todo esto va
dividido en 3
ya ya ya ya cancelamos todo lo que
teníamos en el denominador verdad y aquí
tendríamos 1 x de que es simplemente d
así que ya hemos terminado verdad esta
es la expresión polinomio al que tiene
nuestra nuestra letra de verdad es la
expresión que estábamos buscando de
hecho si sustituimos esta expresión
verdad en en esta ecuación y vamos
simplificando todo lo que obtenemos
entonces al final obtendremos 1 verdad
siempre que el lado izquierdo esté
definido porque por ejemplo habla habrá
valores de ye para los cuales este lado
izquierdo no está definido verdad por
ejemplo no sé no no no podríamos tomar
valores de ye para los cuales este
denominador sea 0 por ejemplo ye igual a
0 hace que el denominador se anule
también ya igual a menos 9 por ejemplo
aunque entonces en realidad no podríamos
tomar algunos valores de ye pero en
realidad no nos están pidiendo
determinar esos valores verdad
simplemente nos pedían descubrir cuáles
la expresión de d para la cual esta
ecuación es está digamos esta división
de expresiones racionales siempre nos da